[Music]
let's go to cameron next in tampa
florida cameron how can we help
howdy uh so
i'm basically just gonna explain my
situation and hopefully y'all can either
knock me outside the head or you know
say you're doing good and here's some
videos are we that aggressive ken well
he wants us to be sure okay you tell us
what you want it's his show his call
so currently i'm in the
market for looking for a home and
basically the criteria that i have for a
home is
uh i don't know if you'll familiar with
the term house hacking but essentially
you're going to live in one room rent
out the additional room and it should be
enough to cover the mortgage on the
house um so i'm looking for a three
bedroom two bath and um the market is
extremely aggressive
most people are playing far above list
i've already put in offers with you know
ten thousand above list with the weight
wave to price expenses of course they
still fit the criteria that i listed out
before um but i is this a good plan is
this something i should pursue further
because basically the only way i'm going
to get a house at this point is to go
way above over what the appraisal's
going to be and then have just extra
money that's going to be given towards
the loan um you know kind of that i
won't be able to get a mortgage for
so i guess basically my question goes
out is how far should i send myself out
i am you know i am debt free and i do
have plenty of money saved up for the
house but uh you know is is this how
much how much do you have saved
so right now it's about 32 000 and
that's just specifically set aside for
buying a house and how much are these
houses you're looking at
my price range is anywhere from about
200 to 250.
okay
so this house hacking idea i i do know
about it and it's done by a lot of the
the real estate investing gurus on tick
tock and they're all you know pushing it
and i love that you're debt-free it
makes me wary already it does and i'm a
fan of you buying the house that you can
afford regardless of who may or may not
rent and who may or may not give you the
money that you want yeah can i jump in
george before you give more financial
advice i just gotta know
why
are you married single like well i need
to understand like what's the purpose of
buying something that you then turn
around and rent two of the three
bedrooms to somebody else is this
straight like investment play for you
and you're trying to is that the deal so
that you relationally this isn't
affecting your life
no so currently um i graduated last year
from texas and then moved to tampa for
work um i'm currently renting out an
apartment it's fairly expensive and as
i'm looking at real estate prices
what rents are going for you know it's
only going up and up and up the longer i
hold on to money the more it's going to
be eaten away by inflation it's a
basically real estate it's a pretty safe
place to keep money and so it's gonna be
basically you know tackling the purpose
of i have a place to put my money that's
safe and i'll be able to you know live
for free essentially is kind of the hope
there's no such thing as no such thing
as free my man i'm sorry yeah i wish
here's your first myth you've been
watching tick tock or
these motivational morons that are
standing by jets and taking pictures and
duping people like you and they're
freaking you out and scaring you that
keeping your money safe is somehow
stupid inflation isn't going to continue
at the crazy rate it is now it's just
not
so cameron let me give you some
parameters that will help because you
have your own set i'll tell you what i
would do if i was in your shoes i would
save up 10 to 20 down you have you have
that but i would do it on a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage
and i want that payment to be no more
than a quarter of your take-home pay
regardless of whoever rents look at that
as gravy on top and if you can afford a
place like that that's less than 25 of
your take-home pay on the 15-year fix
you've got 10 to 20 down ideally 20 or
more to avoid that pmi then i would say
hey this is a great idea man which may
mean you need to wait a few more months
save up a little more and right now the
market is crazy and you're putting 10 20
over asking do not waive inspections do
not waive appraisals that's how you get
into a mess and it becomes it goes from
free to very expensive because you
didn't look into all the issues so don't
rush into this you're a young guy you're
sharp you're doing great but this may
mean this is a three-year journey for
you instead of a tomorrow thing
not what you wanted to hear i'm
sure well i mean
you're right then it's something that i
was prepared for you know that's kind of
why i came on the call it's just like i
said to get knocked inside the head if
it was necessary well we're really not
knocking you upside down because here's
the deal you're a really sharp guy and
you're debt free and you're young and
you've got enormous financial potential
i i think what i'm hearing cameron is
that
you're hearing some influences
that make you feel like if you don't
move this money and get it into real
estate now you're really blowing it and
that's simply not the case george did a
wonderful job of laying out what the
risks are and what the myths are so hang
tight keep building keep hustling man
get more money and do it in a way that's
stable and do it in a way that makes the
most sense you're fine
stay the course i don't like mixing
investment property with my primary
residence yeah it's got its place but
right now you got to focus on you man
you'll do fine in life they already are
doing incredible thank you so much for
the call